but you know how some lads were going
like to thailand and they would like go
over the [ __ ] for experience
shout out to them mando did you ever do
that hell no bev so what happens in
thailand state and thailand no i've
never been bred from no i'm i'm from
elin breve
big man tenure is castillo first aka the
main event aka the sniper bat shout out
to your baby now big man senior we live
in a world full of clout chasers bravo
and i'm sick of it why can't a real g
let me find some real love grab you
could get nosebleeds when you get the
wrong naan bread how this is gonna work
is i'm actually gonna slap money in
front of these galbraiths 1000 for my
eternal love and i'm gonna try and find
out if the girl them are here for the
money and clown or they're there for
real love bro big man thing this is
cloud chasers brad
my name is esther
i am a trainee solicitor in terms of my
passion i'm an actor and presenter well
i'm here to go on a date with castillo
i don't know how that's gonna go
i'm giving love a shot you know doing
different things to find love
my perfect man
that's caring
good looking
i know it's a bit fictitious but um
ambitious i like a very hard-working man
someone that's got serious ideas in his
head i will actually acknowledge there
is double standing in our society i'm
not going to lie even i uphold those
double sellers i can't lie because when
i go on a first date i actually expect a
man to pay i will offer i'll always
offer but if you let me i'll be looking
at you sometimes away
okay are you a man or are you a mouse
i would say my must-have in a
relationship is just to match my energy
i want someone like me like a male
version of me
inspire me because i'm a very
hard-working person like the stuff i
want in a man is the stuff that i have
i'm hard working i take care of my looks
like i spend so much money on my makeup
and my hair so i expect you to look good
go to the gym because i go to the gym
and i even want you to teach me i want
to be like babe have you looked into
this that's the kind of thing like i
want something to match my energy and
take me that level higher whatever thing
with a breakdown
i
pray i do not have to be i need you to
understand the importance of money in
life you know if you're broke you can't
do nothing are we just going to sit
there and just be eating bread all the
time like no we need to go out i like
thai food i want to go to the shop you
know what i mean but i'm
about building with you
[Music]
thought i'd make an effort yeah
you're good you look good
thank you
i liking hearing that
contouring all that looking good
where did you just tremble from
i just came from bromley wow i don't
know what it is but it sounds fun
southeast
but then it's also ken a lot of people
beef bye they're like oh no it's in kent
and some people i know he's in london
isn't it brixton yeah it's close to
brixton no no don't know no yeah i love
how you know the ghetto and cool brixton
is a beautiful area but let's not do
that you get bus up in brixton there's
baby
it's mad so i'm looking for love yeah
you know that right okay yeah so as my
little profile's elevating and all that
stuff yeah i'm looking for the right one
because there's bare clout chasers out
here so what this is about yeah what my
show's about is finding the right one
and separating them from the cloud
chasers so are you a cloud chaser do you
think i'm a couch chaser do i look like
a
chaser
yeah
i'm not being bad like a little bit i'm
not gonna lie but are you though
what makes me look like a clown jason i
know like your smile is very happy
brother like you see all 32 teeth
i'm not gonna lie
happiness i'm a real person and that's
actually why i wanted to come on this
date because i've seen some of your
stuff
and you just say as it is do you say it
as it is yeah i've got verbal diary as
well but i think you're worse than me
though i've seen some of the stuff you
say and i'm like but i rate you for it
do you know what i see you as you're
like cardi b
i'm like a girl shout out to the lgbt
community where we don't know i'm like a
girl
so you're blunt like that as well yeah
not as vulgar as you but you still speak
this yeah yeah yeah i will say as it is
like i don't
know
things yeah so what's your body count
okay no no no no we're not we're not
talking about my body count okay i don't
know i find that weird when people ask
about body counts well what's wrong with
asking because i don't even like keep
count
you can't when you when did you lose
count
no no listen i didn't lose count i just
don't put any significance on it so i
never count it because to me
my sexual experience got nothing to do
with my new relationship do you know
what i mean and it doesn't mean it's
high or low it's just why should i even
care about it why do people care about i
don't i don't even get why people care
about it because it's kind of like a cv
in it like it's like a dbs check and she
got me in you kind of want to know the
dangerous willies that your girl has
taken because it could be some criminal
willies in there so you care about body
counts
for the wifey yeah for the random girl
i'm linking not really but would you say
wifey needs to have you got to be
reasonable in it so what's reasonable to
you i think under 12 is now 12 right
around 12 is a good number because
you've got a you have
yeah that's all right 12. but at the
same time if you meet the right person
it's the right it's yours
pressure and pain on all digital
platforms you want your wifey to be
under 12 but you're not not under 12 we
could hit the 12 to
just
yeah yeah right around there but is that
the same as yours though
pressure and pain in all digital
platforms bev
so that's what i got ask you but let's
get into the thing so i'll ask you this
so
like i'm an open book so i want you to
be an open book and be real so are you a
jealous person
yes and no
if i really really like you i'll be very
jealous
but i don't think i've ever experienced
that with anyone so you've never done
anything mad to like a partner in terms
of jealousy like you found out he's
cheating you see something in his phone
he never done anything out of jealousy
no i think it's reasonable like if
you're dating someone and then you see
them chatting to another girl so what
would you do like you literally rave or
your man you went there together it
seems just chances of next thing what
are you doing no i i personally i would
just move on you would move on yeah like
i would just not talk to you so you
wouldn't go to her as a woman you
wouldn't come to her as a woman no no
like what's the point like the guy's
already violated you
so to me like you don't respect me so
what why am i fighting for so you just
allow it in it the only time i would do
something and i have
is if
you're chatting
you're chatting nonsense to me and then
you're talking to
other girls and then i found out on your
phone or something so when you say like
so are you two dating or you're not just
chatting and then you find out his
chat's up again yeah you're just lying
to me if i found out that you violated
so what are you going to do in that
stage
you're going to be you're going to bear
the two um i mean what i've done in the
past is basically some guy logged on on
my facebook you'll probably see this he
looked on my facebook and i seen all the
girls like i felt really bad for the
girls because he had girlfriends and
like all these girls you were trying to
break free when they have aged
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah they
were out of age
um when he logged on my face i did like
a facebook status i was like really
young again so he did a status on his
team yeah i wrote a thing for satan
saying that he's been to church and he
wants to um
obviously you've all got into it that's
a matter of the lord's life around and
he wants to apologize to all these girls
so i put all the girls in my face i
ended myself as her and i mentioned all
of that and i was like i said like i'm
really sorry i hope you can forgive me
and then i said if you want to speak to
me here's my address
big man it's not looking good
i would be like gun girl i feel like if
you hurt me
i'm a bit like i need to show you pain
as well you need to show him pain yeah
but i wouldn't fight a girl like i
wouldn't i'm a slow killer do you know
what i mean so you just ruin his life
yeah i'll ruin your life and then
yeah but i wouldn't like comments that
shine in your face you know i mean like
what's the point that's good to know
so basically don't lie to me if this
ever goes anywhere what about you are
you a jealous person no brev if you do
something mad i'll just never chat to
you again in life i'm gone rev really
you've
as in like i don't expect nothing less i
probably went into the tick knowing that
she'd probably move a bit mad so it's
just one of the things that i just gotta
anticipate for did you get me yeah if
she's loyal that's the surprise i'll be
like yo you're loyal because i've been
doing bad cheating so bad thing now we
can work now we can build
yeah you say you're quite a negative
person with people i just don't believe
nobody i think everybody's chatting
that's why we're here trying to decipher
who's after the clout and he's after
real love
you get me but speaking of which though
oh can i just ask as well
why are you doing this like why are you
doing a show and looking for love like
you can literally can look for your dms
and just go and date someone something
that gets a bit techy bravo you don't
want to go through the dm's breath
because next thing you say hello to
someone then you end up on a register
it's romantic you don't know where it
will go
because you don't know what you don't
know who their social media you don't
know no not even that you don't know it
could be a man it could be who knows
what people are these days you get me
shout out to the non-binary people
brother because we don't know i mean you
don't know who you're chatting to one
time somebody said in these pictures of
their party and that they look mad thick
they span around and i saw willy web
it's a dangerous world scary hours but
you know how some lads were going like
to thailand and they would like go over
the ladyboya for experience
shout out to their mandolin
hell no bev so what happens in thailand
state and thailand no i've never been
brave from no i'm i'm from elin brev
yeah
so you don't travel much i've traveled
recently i went to new york and chicago
big mountain shout out to the real
drillers bev shout out to the real
drillers out there they will murk people
for nothing over there already it's real
it's really great
to the 90 yeah
so who's your middle celebrity crush in
the uk
you know people check this man no but i
do like your personality i do like the
fact that you just lay as it is so you
kind of know what you're going to get
with you you know if you're pissed off
you're pissed off you won't lead someone
on because that's what annoys me about
men like just trying [ __ ] to you for no
reason
on me what's your favorite feature
um
you've got a nice face i feel like i
could see you on the runway don't know
you see you're doing the right things i
like that yeah i like your smile you've
got really nice eyes as well oh i see i
didn't even have to ask you
i feel like you actually are softie
why'd you say that i don't know you've
literally complimented me so much since
i got here yeah you look good i didn't
expect i didn't expect it everything's
nice i see the baby hairs everything's
nice that's that i like that i'm a
connoisseur oh yeah when it comes to the
lady's hair i'm going to take care of
yourself i take care of myself but like
i notice things like makeup hair and all
that and your thing is proper i like
that oh thank you i like that but you
know what i've not like what i didn't
like that you've not done that
you've not actually asked me about
myself
mounting like what i did well you're
meant to be convincing me you're not a
clown chaser that's what the thing is no
that means if you are not interested in
people how can you attract real people
so you need to be glad you said that you
know what i mean you need to actually
dig dig deep as well you can't just put
it i'm not gonna dig real deep
so i saw something about you talking
about guys going down on you let's dig
deep what's that about
what's that about
then we've done the crb checks oh really
you do the crbs here
you're gonna make sure you are who you
are i quite like that if you
are in your dinner thing with someone
and they don't go down and it doesn't
make sense to me what do you mean like
you need it so
yeah like it's a it's a criteria like
you definitely have to
so you need to suck the of the bone in
there yeah i don't especially if you are
like open to no as well so you don't
know and
is there a lot of prep in that like
what's what's that like dude
what's the plan you're asking me yeah i
thought you're like sexually i just want
to know where you're on i actually went
on a show sex clinic mm-hmm and i like
oh you want a sex clinic yeah because
i'm like i like to talk about sex
because i want to have good sex in my
life like i want to die when you say you
want to say
everything in order
any lingering issues that we need to
know anything that might give me
that's what i'm just saying i don't have
anything no i went there because they
see my personality and they're like oh
you like to you you seem like cheerful
and
i will say things because why not you
know i mean we like sex so why can't we
talk about it so that's the vibe and
they kind of needed someone on the show
like that one time i watched it though
and then like it was a bit mad some girl
opened up my legs and it looked like a
mad kebab in there it was
curtains and a lot of folds it looked a
bit disturbing and one time they had a
dude there he had his pizza i was having
a chicken and bacon sandwich bev and he
had smegma on his thing put me off my
dinner yeah i wouldn't go with an issue
anyways that's a bit embarrassing as
well
so let me ask you this though have you
ever caught anything in the past
no no i'm very i'm very like into
protection and this is why i went to sex
clinic as well because just knowing more
about sex like obviously i always know
about safe sex but just the things that
you should be doing do you know what i
mean like sometimes people don't even
know about you can get herpes from
sucking like some people don't even know
that you know i mean it's just no having
more knowledge about sex in general not
just the pleasure because i i wanted to
know more about pleasure as well i love
pleasure but um the safe side of it as
well so these days you've got to be
careful these days i wear a hazmat suit
i only just know i'm literally i wear i
wear outfit on and i just know you're
saying yeah with some wellington boots
every time
because you just seem like you [ __ ]
anything yeah
these days you've got to be careful so
you'd [ __ ] anything but you're safe no
no i don't like anything but even when i
trust the thing i don't trust them you
put your willingness did you say you
looked like a kid before yeah i didn't
even know though
i didn't even know she was all prim and
proper and then she started moving mad
to be honest there's nothing wrong with
a cracker they're just humans as well
you know i mean it's just someone that's
had a bad life shout out to the crickets
in that you hear me now you've got to be
careful blood these days you put your
willy insane and you get alopecia breath
start
i don't like people in the limelight
because they're not careful i feel like
you've got the receipts what's the
receipt
i know some of my friends that have been
there and caught stuff and
are they with us right now they're
they're they're okay they're not not
okay obviously the sexual stds can be
cured but there's some that can't know
about there's something there's some
gifts that keep on giving them
that's true
what's the freakiest thing you've done i
don't want to disclose my friends no
that's fine how about a guidance with
guy do you want your guy to be freaky
yeah
i'm freaky though i'm down for whatever
like you're like tying them up and
things pagan man in there oh peggy oh i
don't know about that what's your fault
is a bit too much just how do you think
he's upset
he's a bit gay like you know i mean you
shout to the lgbt community
there's nothing wrong with gay men but
i'm not into you know you mean i'm into
straight men
people are doing so much like you know
about the dubai porter party no i don't
explain it to me oh my god you don't
know about it
basically it's been disclosed that
influencers are flying to dubai and
they're being made to
for men rich men to shut in their mouth
and then for real
yeah yeah there's a video that went
viral name names name names i don't know
i don't know them it was just a random
influencer and apparently they offered
them like 30k 5k
[Laughter]
change their life yeah that's amazing so
what they didn't know they were going
there and get some mr whippy on them in
that yeah just open your mouth and then
they don't the vid in the video like
even makes her eat it so it was like she
ate the
feces and then he was like i'll not eat
my booty
like groceries like groceries for me
girls i mean i like that without the
without the dudes
how does that feel like to you that's
good like what do you mean someone is
eating you out so is that on your
checklist like you must eat them eat the
party in that yeah 100 like don't get me
wrong like i if you're not open to it
yet we can build it but i would like you
to be there already so would you eat his
body what would you eat his body
sure that's a no for you
i could um see how right now to be fat
i've never had a man ask me if he did
would you be like that's a bit zesty
because where you going with this no not
really because men everyone has their
g-spot there so i can understand you
wanting it
do you know what i mean like i want it
so what are you looking for in terms of
a relationship i'm looking for someone
that's good licking um someone that
takes care of their looks it seems like
is that very is that very important to
you yeah i'm so sorry like uncle's
always come for me and i'm like i'm not
being funny yet you don't even go to the
gym you don't even get a trim like look
at me the reason you want me is because
i spend a lot of money on my makeup i
spend money on my hair like i'll go to
the gym you know what i mean i spend a
lot of money to look this good so who do
you think you are that you can just come
to me and then you're like oh yeah i
want you so no go take care of yourself
so how about so it looks good about
money i like money too but
i don't expect the things that i can't
do from a man
so i i like money so i expect you to
like money i'm not gonna lie like if i
work hard like i do a lot for money like
i work full time i invest if i'm then
with a man that doesn't really care
about money i'm gonna get frustrated do
you know what i mean of course because i
want a guy that can show me other ideas
to be like oh you've got this property
how about we're going to commercial
properties how about we do you know what
i mean i want somebody's like babies i'm
just selling weed likes oh no i can't i
work in the legal sector i'm a trainee
solicitor so
so
[Laughter]
how many times i've heard that so this
one i want to ask you though you said
looks is important so you would date a
guy that's good looking and broke over a
guy that's fat and butters with bare
money i actually would because i would
be sick because if i could do a guy
that's not good looking and has got
money i would have a sugar daddy because
why not do you know what i mean like i
look good like i know you want me so
what's your biggest turn off when it
comes to that though it's the belly the
belly the uncle belly uncle belly and
just not getting a trim sort of
disgusting
ultimate red flag
like i'm yeah i'm massive he's got bad
money he's like your basement could take
you to the buy fly you out i just got a
belly nah i've got i've had that though
that's the thing i've had men literally
offer me money like i will fly you out
and i'm like but i have to actually suck
something i need to they expect you to
do something whether they want you to
suck though
mean no one's flying you out for free
are they
let's be real
like that when you get there you
probably have like a gang members like
they're trying to they're trying to pass
the ball on that you know i mean they're
probably trying to do some madness you
probably have like three men waiting for
you and then so you're not on that
no i really especially when i have sex
it's because i want to i never want to
be paid for sex have you got virgins
that will do that of course we're going
to put their name in the credits
when i reach out to them
why are you so bothered though like
sometimes that's that works for people
do you know what i mean like uncles
going for girls that want money it works
for them no i agree 100
i think anybody should do whatever they
want to do with their 90s you got me
i feel like i feel like it should be up
for sale i feel like people should do
whatever they want you gotta mean it's
theirs their body their choices
yeah hundred percent
see that's so bad though you shouldn't
judge them it's just i'm
dropping mr whippy's on you rev i'm not
watching you brother this is not gonna
happen in life
i mean i'm gonna look you in the face
these times some men's poop who's been
all over your bottom lip that's a mad
life she buys you a nice whip with that
a nice whip yeah like your girls i'm not
going to dubai but then that means it
was painful in poo poo money brev i
don't know brother i feel like loki when
she looks in the mirror there's gonna be
a lot of demons there brother and it's a
bit mad i don't want that
the energy's transfer brev yeah you're
right you're right
do you know what i've always thought do
you think people
women only want you because you're funny
i'm not even that funny breth women
hilarious now women like me because i'm
buff that's really what it is you're
actually saying that i'm mad buff wow i
like your energy i'm not gonna lie
better i literally you see i was broke
for years and i never had no peas and i
was just getting big yeah oh okay yeah i
mean so really and truly
it was probably a mix of the looks and
the personality brother but i was quite
your confidence like you can tell you're
the type like you have no money in your
bank account but you will tell a rich
man to sit down now of course brother
you get me sky's the limit you get me
like this i think that's what women want
though they just want a confident guy
depends on it because these days people
want peas now brad that's why we're here
doing the level money thing get me if i
had like a grand right now and i just
put it right here
yeah and i said you could have this
money right now are you choosing that or
you choosing love what would you choose
if i was in love with someone i
definitely go for like the love so
that's what you're looking for yeah of
course like i've never experienced love
and i think it's quite sad that's a bit
meh you've never experienced love so
you've just been [ __ ] this whole time
that's what you've been doing that's
that's what it sounds like what can i
say i like a good sex so the 90s has
been on a lease and finance
no no i've been in relationships but i i
don't know maybe because i don't
understand love what do you mean i don't
think i understand this whole being with
someone forever like i've never been
obsessed with someone and never in your
life so a man's never given you the good
willy and you're just obsessed with him
oh no i could never get obsessed because
of collapse
everywhere
no i get good sex okay good good but
you've never been hypnotized or nothing
in your life no because any guy that's
giving me good sex are crazy what do you
mean what do you mean by crazy
oh my god i don't even want to like go
into it like i've had some guy
literally
we've done a thing
and then he's showing up in my in front
of my mom's house trying to sell his car
in front of my african mom's house
what do you mean this guy can't boost
him
and the funny thing is he's not even
like when you see him on social media
you think he's them rich man because
he's got drip like he's got like tattoos
everywhere he's a big guy
and then sounds like he's kind of known
is he kind of known he's kind of famous
sounds like he is
oh i wouldn't think it's not that famous
he's got about 100 and something k yes
he's not really unpopular that's quite a
popular man
yeah it's not if we did our due
diligence we could find him why are you
trying to get it i'm just saying i'm
just saying i'm just saying tell me
something else that turns you on now
give me another turn on for you i guess
eating me out
so that's really i feel like this is a
really important thing for you yeah why
is it so important well if a guy
literally everything's perfect yeah like
you know the moments come yeah god you
will make it a he's kissing on his belly
working his way down and he's like nah
babe i don't really i don't really eat
pork on that you get me man's vegan now
you get me it's not on there what are
you saying in that moment i literally
just tell him like i got problem i i try
and teach her i've had it before because
a lot of black men they think it's this
like it's cool to say i don't eat like
you think they're lying yeah of course a
lot of them are lying i think it's
because society is kind of like
it's deemed disgusting to do it so they
feel like they have to say it i don't do
it or i can only do it with different
types of women but what do you mean
different types of women what's that
because they say like maybe because you
you're not at that wifey stage
yeah so they're like oh i can only do it
when at your wifey and it's like
you think that's [ __ ]
yeah i think no sorry if we're gonna
have sex and you want me to work on it
then you're gonna have to go down there
and eat it like a goosey soup like do
you know what i mean it's an exchange do
you know what i mean you see women they
say they want a guy that's honest with
them from the jump yeah so if a guy just
told you your babies man just want to
beat brother that's all i want to do
would you prefer that honesty over to
someone that was just not telling you
what it was yeah of course if he was
honest with you would you be i mean if i
was into him why not like trey songz
said to me i'm trying to beat up alone
okay
so why troy songs though
because he's bath so does that mean
let's say like anthony joshua and that
came through and he was like yo babes
man what's the smash what are you saying
we're opening it different directions
wide open
because have you seen anthony joshua
like really
and it's not even just his looks it's
the person that he is like the confident
ambitious like everything about him is a
turn on
so i gotta ask you before we wrap up
this beautiful date have you enjoyed
yourself yeah i have i have i feel like
literally
i just got to be myself and i didn't
really expect you to be like this
just like chilled and so like the
compliments i didn't expect it of course
you gotta compliment a beautiful person
so you look good you made it effort so i
gotta do that yeah
great time getting to know you
you get me i've had a great time with
you understanding you a bit more you get
me building to the next bit yeah yeah i
love that no i appreciate that and you
know how you always plug your stuff i
need you to say unleash podcasts out on
all platforms big mentioning how much
you're paying me for that
you say it look at the camera and plug
your teeth unleash broadcast out on all
platforms big man singles now i'll read
that so much about you i love that so
after this date what are you saying
level clout what would you choose
yo you see more flirty and stuff but i'm
like you could just be
just the way you are and you could not
be on it because i don't want it like
bread as well do you know what i mean
well i'm like on it and then he's like
but we shall see we'll see we'll see but
thank you so much it's been a great day
it's been lovely lovely get back safe
don't know thank you
big man thing
i was feeling the date you get me she
was looking all nice and that but you
never know about it sounded a bit clouty
but i'm not gonna lie but i'm not gonna
lie
what do you think about black people and
i'm just joking i'm taking them i try
and mess you up i'm not gonna do that
man i can't argue with then it's like i
feel like if i'm doing that then i go
next thing i've got to be on rupaul's
drag race brother i'll give you enough
yelling someone on instagram he he
called me a slapper what's what's what's
what's his instagram so we could tell
him to suck his mum back
you